that there is this huge variety of different sizes,
shapes and even colors.
The feather is one of the most astonishing pieces of technology
invented by the natural world,
and for centuries, this feather has helped birds to keep dry,
to keep warm and even power flight.
Only one section of the tree of life can actually make a feather.
Among all the world's animals,
birds are the only ones who can make something
like what I'm holding today.
I personally have given them a nickname,
and I like to call them the feathermakers.
It is the major difference between birds and any other animals we have on earth,
and if you can't make a feather, you cannot call yourself a bird.
(Laughter)
For us humans, who are earthbound,
birds represent freedom.
This feather has enabled birds to conquer gravity
and take to the air in an extraordinary way.
Don't you sometimes wish you could fly like a bird?
Birds are my passion,
and I want to change the way each one of you thinks about them.
The easiest reason I love them so much is because they are beautiful.
There are 10,000 species in the world,
and each one of them is uniquely beautiful.
Birds are amazing,
and this talk is dedicated to all the birds of the world.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Indeed, these birds have been part of our lives and cultures
all over the world for centuries,
and every society has a story about birds.
You probably have heard childhood stories of different birds
and how they relate with man.
I personally recently learned
that our human ancestors would follow flocks of vultures
and then they would help them
to identify where carcasses have been dropped by large carnivores,
and these humans will scavenge and eat part of that meat.
Birds have been used as brands and labels all over the world.
You know the bald eagle?
It was chosen as the national emblem for the US
because of its majestic strength,
beautiful looks
and even a long lifespan.
And just like us humans
who have managed to live in virtually all habitats of this earth,
birds have also conquered the world.
From birds such as these beautiful penguins
that live in the cold ice caps
to even others like the larks,
who live in the hottest deserts you can imagine.
Indeed, these species have conquered this world.
Birds also build houses like us.
The real pros in housebuilding
are a group of birds we call the weaverbirds,
and this name they were given
because of the way in which they weave their nests.
An interesting one:
birds also love and date just like us humans.
In fact, you'll be surprised to know that males dress to impress the women,
and I'll show you how.
So here we have a long-tailed widowbird,
and this is how they would normally look.
But when it comes to the breeding season,
everything changes,
and this is how he looks.
(Audience murmurs)
Yeah?
Birds also, multiple species of them,
do love to touch and cuddle just like humans.
And I know you're wondering about this one.
Yes, they kiss too,
sometimes very deeply.
(Applause)
Some have even learned to cheat on their spouses.
(Laughter)
For example, the African jacana:
the females will mate with multiple males
and then she takes off to find other males to mate with
and she leaves the male behind to take care of the chicks.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
And birds help us so much,
and they play very crucial roles in our ecosystems each day.
Vultures clean up our environment
by literally digesting disease-causing pathogens,
and they finish carcasses that would otherwise cost us lots of money
to clear from the environment.
A sizable flock of vultures is capable of bringing down a carcass
the size of a zebra straight to the bone
within just about 30 minutes.
Owls help to rid the environments of rodents
and this helps us a lot because it saves us money --
we don't lose our crops --
and secondly, we don't have to buy harmful chemicals
to handle these rodents.
The beautiful sunbirds we see in our environments
are part of nature's pollination crew,
and they help our plants to form fruits.
Together with other pollinators like insects,
they have actually helped us
to get most of the food crops that we depend on for many years.
Unfortunately, the story of birds is by far not perfect.
They are faced by numerous challenges every day wherever they live.
Top on the threats facing birds
is habitat loss
and reduced food availability.
Birds are also hunted, especially migratory species
and ducks that congregate in water bodies.
Poisoning is happening to flocks that like to stick together,
especially in places like rice schemes.
Moreover, power lines are electrocuting birds
and wind farms are slicing birds
when they fly through the blades.
Recently, we've heard the talk of climate change
making a lot of headlines,
and it's also affecting birds,
because birds are being forced to migrate to better breeding and feeding grounds
because unfortunately where they used to live
is no longer habitable.
My own perspective towards birds was changed
when I was a small boy in high school,
and there was this boy who struck,
injuring the wing and the leg of a bird we called the augur buzzard.
I was standing there,
just a mere 14-year-old,
and I imagined a human being in a similar situation,
because this bird could not help itself.
So even if I was hardly any biologist by then,
I gathered with three of my friends and we decided to house the bird
until it had regained strength and then let it free.
Interestingly, it accepted to feed on beef from our school kitchen,
and we hunted termites around the compound for its dinner every day.
After a few days, it had regained strength
and we released it.
We were so happy to see it flap its wings
and fly off gracefully.
And that experience changed the way we looked at birds.
We went on to actually make a magazine,
and we called it the Hawk Magazine,
and this was in honor of this bird
that we had helped within our own high school.
Those experiences in high school made me the conservationist I am today.
And a passion for birds should especially matter for Africa
and all Africans,
because among all other continents,
Africa hosts some of the most amazing bird species
you can find anywhere in the world.
Imagine having a name like "shoebill."
That's the name of that bird.
And there are countries like DR Congo,
Tanzania, Uganda and Kenya
who are leading the continent in highest numbers of diversity
when it comes to the species.
These birds continue to provide the continent
with very crucial ecosystem services that Africa needs.
Moreover, there is huge potential
for Africa to lead the world in avian tourism.
The economy will definitely benefit.
Imagine how many communities will benefit from groups of tourists
visiting their villages just to see the endemic birds
that can only be found in those villages.
How can we help birds together?
There is now a chance for all of you
to turn your passion for birds
into contributing to their continued survival,
and you can do that by becoming a citizen scientist.
Citizen science is a growing trend around the world,
and we are having scenarios where people are sharing information
with the rest of the community about traffic updates,
security alerts and so on.
That is exactly what we realized as bird-watchers,
and we thought, because birds are found everywhere,
if we've got all of you and everyone else in Africa
to tell us the birds they find where they live,
where they school, or even where they work,
then we can be able to come up with a map of every single species,
and from there scientists will be able
to actually prioritize conservation efforts
to those habitats that matter the most.
Take for example these two projects,
the Africa Raptor DataBank,
which is mapping all birds of prey in the continent of Africa,
and the Kenya Bird Map,
which is mapping about 1,100 species that occur in my country, Kenya.
These two projects now have online databases
that are allowing people to submit data,
and this is converted into very interactive websites
that the public can consume and make decisions from.
But when we started, there was a big challenge.
We received many complaints from bird-watchers,
and they will say,
"I'm in a village, and I cannot access a computer.
How do I tell you what birds live in my home,
or where I school, or where I work?"
So we were forced to renovate our strategy and come up with a sustainable solution.
It was easy:
we immediately realized that mobile phones
were becoming increasingly common in Africa
and most of the regions could get access to one.
So we came up with mobile phone applications
that you can use on your iPhone and on your Android phone,
and we made them freely available
for every bird-watching enthusiast out there.
So we came up with BirdLasser, which is used by the Kenya Bird Map,
and also we have the African Raptor Observations,
which is now used by the African Raptor DataBank.
This was a huge breakthrough in our work
and it made us get enormous amounts of data
from every birder out there in the regions.
With this, we realized that citizen science
is indeed very powerful,
the reason being, citizen science is adaptive.
And we were able to actually convert many bird-watchers
to start sharing new information with us.
When we were starting,
we didn't know that birds could be a huge gateway
to approaching conservation of other forms of animals.
Interestingly, now in the Virtual Museum for Africa,
we have maps for dragonflies and damselflies,
butterflies and moths,
reptiles, frogs, orchids, spiders,
scorpions, and yes, we are even mapping mushrooms.
Who could have imagined mapping mushrooms?
So this showed us that indeed we've created a community of people
who care about nature in Africa.
I hereby call upon all of you
to join me in promoting the value of birds
within your communities.
Please just tell your friends about birds,
for we are always inclined to love and care for that which we know.
Please spend a few minutes in your free time
when you are at work, at school, or maybe at home,
to at least look around you and see which beautiful birds are there.
Come join us in citizen science
and tell us the birds you're finding in the places where you visit.
Even simpler,
you could buy your child or your sibling
a pair of binoculars
or a bird book
and let them just appreciate how beautiful these birds are.
Because maybe one day they will want to care
for that one which they know and love.
The children indeed are our future.
Let us please teach them to love our feathermakers,
because the love of birds
can be a huge gateway to appreciating all forms of nature.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Thank you.